six nurses who work on the same ward at
a medical center in winston-salem North
Carolina are sharing a serendipitous
connection all of them are pregnant and
do between the end of the July and mid
December they found out within months of
each other and there was even a unique
twist with one of their discoveries Dana
Jacobson co-host of CBS this morning
Saturday spoke with four of the
soon-to-be mothers about their shared
journey the joke around the clinic these
days don't drink the water
Sabrina Hudson Nikki hue 'the bethany
stringer and nine a day are nurses at an
outpatient oncology clinic at the Wake
Forest Baptist Medical Center we work
together really well and we're just
close they are all pregnant right now
but say it wasn't on purpose how is it
even possible that six of 27 nurses in
the same Ward are pregnant at the same
time within a three and a half month
time with the delivery day it's meant to
be that we're supposed to share this
journey together and it is truly special
and hard to put into words I was the
first to get pregnant and soon after
Bethany was pregnant and then it was
like a conversation while I wonder if
there's more because things happen in
three easily found out there was a third
then there was a fourth Sabrina was the
fifth to tell their manager Katie the
good news I was like please don't be mad
but I'm also I was like Katie it would
be hilarious if you were pregnant it
wasn't meant to be a prediction but a
month later from the bathroom she's like
can you come here and I was like okay
what's her home she's like nothing's
wrong just come here and so slowly by
slowly each one of us went to the
bathroom and we were all in there
together and I'm sure you could have
heard us everywhere cuz we were so
excited almost like in the bathroom like
screaming like the patients in this
cancer ward where life can seem fleeting
are having fun with the baby boom one
patient has dubbed the pregnant nurses
the fabulous six pack have you seen a
little joy brought in here because
they see the six of you definitely
brightens their face you can see it and
while they didn't plan to get pregnant
together the women say this is not a
coincidence my husband and I tried for
almost a year so for all this to happen
like at the same time it's just really
mind-blowing what we're most excited
about is future playdates and getting a
picture getting a picture all the bumps
was fine but getting a picture of all
the babies to be here for CBS this
morning Dana Jacobson winston-salem
North Carolina expect me to follow ups
crying yeah it's gonna be a ready-made
playgroup